hay una sola manera de entender la
moralidad o las normas del islam
no es una pregunta muy interesante
porque hoy en día en el islam no existe
una sola rama o una interpretación del
islam en realidad hoy en día en el islam
tenemos más de 70 corrientes ramas
diferentes facciones entonces tenemos
diferentes formas de interpretar y
aplicar la sharía que es el camino
religioso o la ley islámica en este
asunto la interpretación de los
talibanes es una interpretación muy
rigurosa muy polémica y que incluso la
mayoría de los musulmanes lo rechazan y
no están de acuerdo con tal
interpretación en el caso de la
comunidad musulmana amarilla nosotros
condenamos principalmente su
interpretación y su aplicación de la
sharía de la ley islámica e incluso
muchos de sus asuntos y su
interpretación de la sharía contradice a
los propios principios y mandamientos y
leyes de la sharía no en probar en el
blog el caso de la mujer la sharía
otorga a la mujer el derecho de obtener
educación desde la tumba desde la cuna
hasta la tumba y por ejemplo los
talibanes no interpretan la sharía en
una forma totalmente opuesto a la propia
sharía imán usted es justamente lo
estaba mencionando pero le pregunto qué
riesgos que otros riesgos conlleva a
este ministerio para la población afgana
y sobre todo para las mujeres y para las
niñas
es muy preocupante y realmente doloroso
porque ellos en realidad ocultan
esconden su propia ideología
su propia agenda no es importante
aclarar que los talibanes es un
movimiento principalmente que surgió en
un contexto como un movimiento militar
con una agenda geopolítica y ellos
tienen su propia ideología sus propias
tradiciones normas culturales pero lo
más preocupante y triste para el mundo
musulmán es que ellos ocultan a su
ideología con la tapa del islam y en ese
asunto obviamente es el gran peligro que
ellos ahora conforme su propia
interpretación del islam o de la sharía
van a usurpar los derechos de cualquier
persona que se opone a su ideología y
obviamente ahí la el grupo más
vulnerable son los grupos religiosos o
las minorías religiosas y obviamente
también la mujer y van a imponer a la
mujer su propia ideología en nombre del
islam y obviamente eso es como muy
preocupante muy alarmante para el mundo
musulmán y también una gran mancha para
la imagen del islam
usted también menciona esto de algo pero
quiero que lo amplíe por favor realmente
el islám ordena los castigos y las
restricciones a las libertades que están
imponiendo los talibanes con la
interpretación varía según esta cultura
y el lugar no así no incluso analiza los
diferentes puntos que han anunciado los
talibanes sobre su interpretación de la
ley de la ley islámica y de la sharía si
lo comparamos directamente con la sharía
encontramos realmente una gran
contradicción y es una diferencia entre
día y noche y solamente para hablar por
ejemplo el velo la burka la sharía el
propio corán anuncia que no hay coacción
en la fe es decir que nadie en ninguna
institución sea religiosa o política
tiene el derecho de imponer algo en
nombre de dios porque el corán anuncia
no hay coacción en la fe en la religión
después como ya dije el islam ya en el
siglo 7 otorgó a la mujer el derecho de
obtener educación de votar de ser una
parte productiva y activa de la sociedad
de heredad propiedad de manejar
libremente dinero de casarse por su
propia conexión incluso el derecho de
divorcio entonces hay una larga lista de
derechos que la mujer ya recibió y 27 y
los talibanes lamentablemente
interpretan el islam conforme sus
propios intereses y ocultan y eso es lo
más triste que usan la tapa del islam
para realizar su ideología y para
imponer su ideología y obviamente es una
dictadura cuyas herramientas principales
es la violencia es
usurpar los derechos y oprimir las voces
de las minorías en este caso de las
mujeres
desde su percepción el gobierno talibán
y sus acciones podrían provocar una
especie de estigmatización de la
comunidad musulmana a nivel mundial sí
creo que ya lo ocurrió si nosotros
analizamos porque no es la primera vez
que los talibanes gobiernan el país ya
lo hicieron desde los años 1996 y 2001 y
si uno analiza la situación de los
musulmanes en el occidente la
islamofobia la generalización de los
estereotipos los prejuicios
aumentó en las últimas dos décadas 6 hay
más choques hay más confrontaciones
al contexto lo que ocurre en afganistán
o con los talibanes con al qaeda
obviamente ellos fomentan y ellos
activamente manchan la imagen del islam
y fomentan los prejuicios contra los
musulmanes pero acá me gustaría aclarar
que ellos no representan las enseñanzas
verdaderas del islam ni siquiera es una
parte importante adentro del mundo
musulmán tenemos alrededor de un casi
2.000 millones musulmanes en el mundo y
la gran mayoría la mayoría de las
escuelas teológicas
rechazan el talibán y su forma de
interpretar el islam